good evening everyone on behalf of the
tattered covered bookstore it's my
pleasure to welcome you and to thank you
for supporting independent bookstores
Viviane Spitz is a fellow of the Academy
of professional reporters of the
National Court Reporters Association and
was an official reporter of debates and
chief reporter in the United States
House of Representatives from 1972 until
1982 in 1978 she reported President
Carter's establishment of the
President's Commission on the Holocaust
appointing world-famous Holocaust
survivor and later Nobel laureate Elie
Wiesel as chairman by contract with the
United States War Department mrs. Fitz
reported the Nuremberg war crimes trial
trials in Germany from 1946 until 1948
since 1987 she had has made
presentations on the Nazi doctor doctors
case to over 45,000 students and adults
in the United States Canada and
Singapore in recognition of her
presentations to refute the claims of
Holocaust deniers
she has received five national
humanitarian Awards on December 22nd
1995 the Steven Spielberg visual history
foundation conducted a videotaped
interview of her as a witness to history
in April 2001 the late Tony Randall
producer of judgment at Nuremberg on
Broadway had her appear on stage
following a performance to speak on
April 25th 2005 she appeared on CNN's
Aaron Brown news night launching the
publication of her book doctors from
hell the horrific account of Nazi
experiments on humans the book is now in
the university of colorado medical
school bookstore and is in the deadly
medicine exhibited at the United States
Holocaust Memorial Museum until October
15th on the cover of the third edition
now being printed will appear Elie
Wiesel's endorsement as follows read
Vivien Spitz
personal memoir with its shattering
memories from the Nuremberg trials and
you will encounter physicians who
corrupted by Nazi ideology brought shame
to their profession after tonight's
presentation Vivian will be glad to
answer questions and sign copies of her
book we are honored and delighted the
Vivian Spitz is with us this evening
would you please join me now in making
her feel welcome thank you very much for
inviting me to speak to you this evening
the Nazi doctors case of the Nuremberg
war crimes trials I want to just tell
you a bit about how I came to report
these trials in Nuremberg at such a
young age in 1905 a Spanish born Harvard
educated philosopher named George
Santayana wrote a five volume work
entitled the life of Reason in it he
stated those who cannot remember the
past are condemned to repeat it
and for years now a mission of mine has
been to speak about that past to which
Santa Anna referred especially to all
who were born after 1945 the year the
Nuremberg war crimes trials commenced
these trials from November 1945 through
April 1949 were the first international
criminal trials in all of history with
four countries the United States France
Great Britain and the Soviet Union
trying the leaders of one country
Germany
for crimes against humanity and
calculated genocide perpetrated over a
period of 12 years from 1933 when Adolf
Hitler came to power until 1945 when
world war ii ended these trials were
concerned with three major points basic
human rights and the dignity of life the
difference between good and evil and
indifference to evil in a crime there is
always the perpetrator and the victim
look the other way don't get involved
remain silent and you will always help
the perpetrator and never the victim by
the end of World War two on May 8 1945
most of the major Nazi leaders who had
not already committed suicide were in
the hands of US and British troops
rather than stand them up against the
wall and shoot them on the spot or try
them immediately in summary proceedings
the United States among the big four
powers pushed for a fair trial before an
international military tribunal in which
all accused would be given every
opportunity to present their cases the
tribunal would be committed to strict
rules of evidence growing out of
centuries of legal experience and the
development of law and order among
nations serious and heated debate went
on for many months among the delegates
to the big four powers finally
culminating in a charter agreement at
the London conference in August of 1945
establishing the International Military
Tribunal the Palace of Justice at
Nuremberg was selected because Nuremberg
had been the site of the huge Nazi Party
rallies
the horror story of Nazism began
unfolding before the eyes and ears of
the world at Nuremberg on November 20
1945 the case was titled
in the matter of the United States of
America the French Republic the United
Kingdom of Great Britain em Northern
Ireland and the Union of Soviet
Socialist Republics versus Herman
Wilhelm Goering and 21 other major Nazi
leaders the 66th page indictment of four
counts charged it Commons conspiracy to
seize power establish a totalitarian
regime plan prepare initiate and wage
wars of aggression the violation of the
laws of war crimes against peace crimes
against humanity and crimes of
persecution and extermination now the
Nazis had meticulously recorded by
documentation film and photography
almost all of their atrocities because
tens of thousands of pieces of
documentary evidence had been captured
by the US and Allied forces most facts
presented at the trials were incapable
of being denied or defended of 22
defendants in the major Nazi leader's
case 19 were held accountable for their
crimes individually not collectively 12
were sentenced to death by hanging 10
were hanged on October 16 1946 and four
hours before Goering must be hanged he
swallowed a cyanide capsule which he had
been able to hide on his body
on May 8 1945 when the war ended I was
on my first job in Detroit with a
freelance court reporting agency
publicity about the impending trials was
on the front pages of the newspapers all
across the country and in the movie
theaters on the Movietone news reels we
did not have television at that time
then into our Detroit office one day
came a flyer from the United States War
Department to change my life
significantly
approximately 26 court reporters were
being recruited from all over the United
States to go to Germany to report not
only giri's trial but the 12 subsequent
trials of which the Nazi doctors trial
was the first I applied immediately
wondering if I could possibly be
selected me with so little experience
and with so few to be selected
I waited anxiously in Detroit to hear
from the War Department and I soon heard
I was too young I had to be 21 and I was
only 20 so the next months in Detroit
were unbearable for me as I just tried
to grow old as fast as I could
the first wave of reporters had already
been selected for Gehrig's trial but as
soon as I was 21 I signed a contract
with the War Department and received my
orders in late October 1946 assigned to
the office of chief of counsel for war
crimes Nuremberg Germany on November 6
1946 I arrived in cold snowy bombed out
Nuremberg presented my orders to the
proper military authorities and was
driven to my first assigned home which I
shared for several months with one young
British woman and one young French woman
on the Allied payroll neither of whom
could I understand
for security reasons we were picked up
every morning at our front gate by a
displaced person on the Allied payroll
in a German car and driven to the iron
gates of the Palace of Justice
now with the trial of the major Nazi
leaders over the British the French and
the Soviets packed up and went to their
separate zones in Germany to try other
defendants however many of their
language experts stayed on to work on
the 12 subsequent trials on October 25
1946 the United States only filed an
indictment against 20 Nazi doctors and
three medical assistants entitled the
United States of America versus Carl
brunt Italia and thus commenced the
first and most horrifying of the 12
subsequent trials I wanted this trial
more than any of the others including
Gehrig's trial and I was one of the six
reporters selected to report it from the
beginning to the end now who were these
defendants in the doctor's case Carl
Brown was not only hitler's personal
physician but he was the chief architect
of the program and the machinery which
turned doctors who had taken the oath of
Hippocrates to heal and cure turned into
doctors who became torturers and
murderers in most cases they were
distinguished Germans scientists Chiefs
surgeons and physicians and Institute's
clinics hospitals and universities all
throughout Germany they were the doctors
at the concentration camps who performed
the grisly medical experiments all very
sadistic men and one woman with what
crimes were they charged with the
outright murder of political prisoners
civilians
intellectual dissidents non German
nationals Catholic and Protestant clergy
and prisoners of war through medical
experimentation without their consent in
the name of scientific medical research
those who did not die or who were not
murdered suffered torture maiming and
permanent disfigurement and disability
the victims were nameless ordered like
cattle in wholesale lots of 200 Jews in
good physical condition 50 gypsies 500
tubercular poles 1000 Russian prisoners
of war the 23 doctors and medical
assistants were charged with 12 major
experiments carried out from 1939 to
1945 at Auschwitz Buchenwald Dachau
ravensbrück not spyler Saxon housing and
other camps the first experiment charged
with high-altitude victims were locked
in airtight ball-shaped compartments and
the pressure was altered to simulate
high-altitude atmospheric conditions up
to 68 thousand feet without oxygen the
approximately 200 victims were Russian
and Polish Jews who were termed
professional criminals why because they
had been condemned for racial shame
consisting of marriage or intercourse
between non-aryans
and Aryans the term given to pure
blooded Germans their punishment was the
torture of over 120 and the murder of 70
to 80 the second experiment was freezing
conducted to determine the most
effective means of hitting severely
chilled or frozen people but
victus were placed in long narrow tanks
of ice water for up to three hours at
which point death occurred or by keeping
them outdoors naked 9 to 14 hours in
sub-freezing temperatures they screamed
in pain as parts of their bodies froze
rewarming of those who did not die was
most effective by very hot baths then
Heinrich Himmler chief of the Gestapo
and one of the major Nazi leaders who
committed suicide after he has captured
by the British and therefore was never
tried ordered rewarming by naked women
at one point four gypsy prostitutes
themselves prisoners were produced from
ravensbrück concentration camp and the
chill to unconsciousness naked male
victim was placed between two naked
women indicating the obscene sickness of
Himmler and his doctors malaria
experiments were conducted to a German
prisoners of war Russians yugoslavs and
a large number of Polish Catholic
priests who were infected with malaria
through controlled infected mosquito
bites or by the injections of malaria
infected blood these these victims
suffered permanent disability and
approximately 400 deaths one-third of
the total number of experimental
subjects mustard gas experiments were
conducted to devout to investigate the
most effective treatment of mustard gas
wounds one drop of a liquid gas
substance was applied to the lower arm
of the experimental subject 10 hours
later burns appeared and spread over the
entire body
wherever drops contacted the skin photos
were taken daily fatality started occur
after the fifth day greater parts of the
lungs and other organs were each in the
way some of the victims were forced to
enter the gas chamber smash small
ampules of liquid gas and inhale the
vapor with the same results their lungs
were destroyed of approximately 220
victims over 50 died the fifth
experiment was sulfanilamide I'm not
going to detail every one of these
experiments for you because they are all
in the book one of the most savage
sadistic and inhumane experiments was
bone muscle and nerve regeneration and
bone transplantation in which whole
sections of bone whole legs taken off at
the hips muscles nerves arms including
scapula's were removed from healthy
victims and attempted be transplanted to
other healthy victims these were
predominantly young Polish women which
resulted for the most part in death but
for those who lived mutilation and
permanent disability the seventh
experiment was seawater to develop a
method of making seawater drinkable the
victims were German Czech and polish
gypsies deprived of food and given only
brackish yellow sea water for days
resulting in excruciating pain
foaming at the mouth and eventually in
most cases madness one of the most
dramatic courtroom scenes occurred
during my turn at the courtroom Karl
Holland Rainer
a dark-haired man of small stature
nervous and very excitable assumed the
witness stand
the main courtroom of the Palace of
Justice ruled very large before him it
was June 27 1947
now witness for what reasons were you
arrested by the Gestapo
I'm 29 May 1944
the question was asked in English and
simultaneously interpreted into German
the answer given in German interpreted
through the English Channel of my
earphones was because I am a gypsy of
mixed blood the right citizenship law
dated September 15 1935 red Jews and
gypsies cannot become citizens the law
for the protection of German blood and
German honor dated November 14 1935
another of the infamous Nuremberg Laws
read a marriage shall furthermore not be
contracted if the progeny to be expected
from it would endanger the purity of
German blood Carl holder Rainer was
first sent to Auschwitz then to book an
fault
and then Dachau where sea water
experiments tortured his mind and body
for days question do you think you would
be able to recognize that doctor if you
saw him today
answer yes immediately I would recognize
him at once question would you kindly
stand up from your witness chair take
your earphones off and proceed over to
the defendants duct and see if you can
recognize the professor that you met at
Dachau everyone in the courtroom waited
tensely I watched this little man as he
stood up he paused for just a moment
his eyes seemingly fixed on a doctor in
the second row of the prisoners bucks
then in a flash he was gone from the
witness stand seeming to almost leap
over the MS of the German Defense
Council stables he appeared to be almost
flying through the air
toward the prisoner's dock with his
right arm stretched high reaching for
dr. beagle buck the consulting physician
to the German air force amid the
scramble of defense counsel bending away
from him and momentary shock and
confusion in that courtroom three of our
American military policemen rushed from
behind the prisoners dock and grabbed
this little man almost in midair
doodlee bent on delivering his own brand
of justice I did not see a weapon but I
was told later by an American military
police officer that he had been able to
hide a dagger on his person the AIDS
experiment was epidemic Joseph the ninth
experiment was sterilization conducted
on Russian prisoners of war in Polish
Jews to develop a suitable method for
the sterilization of millions of people
by radiation drugs and surgery in a
planned mass genocide of large
population groups this resulted in
horrible physical and mental pain and
anguish the tenth experiment was typhus
conducted to determine the effectiveness
of vaccines the experimental subjects
were not only German criminals taken
from their own jails but poles Russians
Frenchmen and prisoners of war the
purpose was to manufacture a typhus
convalescent serum infection was
accomplished by laceration of the skin
and the introduction of a typhus culture
by contagious lice or by the intravenous
or intramuscular injection of fresh
blood containing the typhus virus now to
maintain a constant source of infected
fresh blood three to five
mates per month were artificially
infected with typhus these victims
became raving mad suffered delirium and
over 90 percent died a slow and
frightful death and in Denver we have a
survivor of this experiment who told me
that of 50 men selected from his block
at Buchenwald only 17 survived and he
was one of them the electives experiment
was poisoned now some of these 12
experiments had absolutely no scientific
objective to heal or cure but rather to
kill or exterminate and this was one of
them poison bullets were shot into
Russian prisoners of war not to test an
antidote for poison but to time how fast
death occurred taking up to two hours
and nine minutes poison was also
secretly administered in food and the
doctors stood behind curtains to watch
the reactions these victims suffered
excruciating torture and all died or
were deliberately killed to permit
autopsies the last major experiment was
incendiary bomb to test the effect of
pharmaceutical preparations on
phosphorus burns the victims were
inflicted with phosphorus from the bombs
and then the wounds ignited burning the
skin for up to 68 seconds before
extinguishing resulting in intense pain
and suffering at one time 112 Jews were
selected to complete a skeleton
collection for the University of the
right University in Strasbourg France
under Nazi occupation photographs and
anthropological measurements were taken
and the victims were killed
and defleshed and on the cover of the
book is the picture of the doctor who
was not a doctor a medical assistant who
was in charge of this experiment
military tribunal was established on
October 25 1946 to hear the medical case
concluded in on July 19 1947 after the
introduction of 1471 pieces of
documentary evidence for doctors
including Carl brunt were sentenced to
death by hanging
five to life imprisonment two to twenty
years one to 15 years one to ten years
and seven were found not guilty and
released at Carl Brandt's execution on
November 2 1948 before he fell through
the tap trapdoor he declared it is no
shame to stand on this scaffold I served
my fatherland as others before me there
was not one scintilla of any kind of
remorse shown on the part of any one of
these doctors or assistants including
the seven who were acquitted the court
in its detailed final judgment set forth
ten points regarding permissible medical
experiments known as the Nuremberg code
which was the starting point for
research guidelines the code has been
extended by the 1964 Declaration of
Helsinki with subsequent additions and
continues in use today
now all of this Horror Story was to be
the final solution of the Jewish
Question here were people who had this
happen to them just for being who they
were this was coordinated evil and
hatred on a scale unprecedented by a
modern civilized society of my heritage
I am NOT Jewish
I am half German a society that produced
such brilliant writers composers and
scientists as Goethe Khan Bach Beethoven
and yes bogner Hitler's favorite vessel
roentgen and Einstein Adolf Hitler was
not criminally I'm saying he was
criminally sane a link to our common
humanity which should make us all think
about it
our humanity is also linked to the six
million Jews and the millions of
non-jews who made up the almost 11
million victims of the Holocaust
now one cannot easily comprehend that
figure until one sees a copy of the
orders at the Treblinka death camp in
Poland for example for the extermination
of 14,000 per day now the non-jewish
world did not talk much about this
educate about it or commemorate it for
almost 30 years after it happened and I
could never understand why
then on November 1 1978 while I was
chief reporter of debates in the United
States House of Representatives
President Jimmy Carter by executive
order established the President's
Commission on the Holocaust appointing
the later Nobel laureate Elie Wiesel as
chairman on April 2 1979 President
Carter by Proclamation designated April
28 and 29 1979 as days of remembrance of
victims of the Holocaust asking the
people of the United States to observe
this solemn anniversary of the
liberation of Dachau by US Armed Forces
on April 28 and 29 of 1945 this is a
story of the mass violation of basic
human rights and the dignity of life of
indifference to evil of people who knew
and kept silent of heads of state who
looked the other way including our own
and our church leaders too many church
leaders who did not speak out against
what was happening I was neither a
witness nor a victim but I was a
verbatim court reporter of the words
that came from their mouth at Nuremberg
on April 12 1945 General Dwight
Eisenhower supreme commander of the
Allied forces in Europe wrote a letter
to Chief of Staff General George C
Marshall describing his first visit to
one of the camps by US forces quote the
things I saw beggar description the
visual evidence and the verbal testimony
of starvation cruelty and bestiality
were so overpowering as to leave me a
bit sick in one room where there were
piled up twenty or thirty naked men
killed by starvation George Patton would
not even enter he said he would get sick
if he did so I made the visit
deliberately in order to be in a
position to give first-hand evidence of
these things if ever in the future there
develops a tendency to charge these
allegations merely due propaganda and
that is precisely what is happening
throughout the world today with the
insidious spread of Holocaust denial I
have been seriously confronted
by Holocaust deniers the largest
organization in the United States is the
Institute for historical review based in
Newport Beach California I was first
confronted by them in 1997 when I was
speaking at the antlers Hotel in
Colorado Springs to judges and lawyers a
third attorney came up to us before we
got started and said someone is handing
out propaganda in the to the lawyers who
are registering at that moment this man
came bounding up across the floor to me
with a big smile on his face handed me
three sheets of a document and asked me
if I was familiar with their Institute I
looked at the title and said I am very
familiar with your Institute Institute
for historical review but you do not
have the correct title at the top it
should be Institute for historical
revision and Holocaust denial then his
demeanor changed
he became hostile to me and challenged
me to debate him not only on the
Holocaust but on the Nuremberg war
crimes trials which you understand were
a staged production put on by the four
countries and all of the photographs are
fake I said to him I will not only not
debate you I will not dignify with an
answer any question you put to me I have
nothing further to say to you those who
cannot remember the past are condemned
to repeat it and we have not remembered
well we must learn from the lessons of
the past to help us overcome our hatreds
and prejudices of today to structure our
future with faith hope and dedication to
humanity with international
understanding
and justice thank you very much for
listening
[Applause]
now we're going to take questions first
one side of the room and then the next
pardon me oh the tattoos removed from
the prisoners right that was uh Elsa
Koch that was in another trial that I
did not report but yes indeed that did
occur especially with downed Airmen u.s.
airman who had tattoos they made
lampshades out of them and other items
but that was not part of my trial so I
cannot give you details on that
now behind the letting the certain
doctors off completely how could they be
dismissed from their crimes her question
was what was the rationale for letting
me seven doctors off and not be
accountable for their crimes I was
shocked at this as many of us were I
would not have been shocked had there
been three doctors acquitted but you
have to remember that this was the world
was watching these trials the
international press was there from 20
different countries and there had never
been trials like these in the history of
civilization before I feel that the
judges especially the American judges
who were the judges on the twelve
subsequent trials bent over backwards to
show the world that these were not
trials of the victors over the
vanquished but rather of justice over
evil
did you get to meet Rudolf Hess and
what's-his-name Garen fatso Goering and
Albert Speers did you get them no time
to shine
I was too young when that trial went on
and I did not report that trial
I was waiting in Detroit to get old
enough to get there to report the
doctor's trial which was the trial I
wanted with no assurance that I was
going to get it but I did yes especially
the doctors trial the doctors were not
the political or military leaders they
were the educated scientists who had
sworn to do no harm to their patients
they were in totally different category
I wanted to take their testimony to
front try to to try to understand how
they could in my book I go through in
great detail every single one of these
experiments through the testimony of the
witnesses whom I actually reported and
recorded their words
yeah I'm sure it's okay he's got one
here thank you
since the Nazis were known for keeping
meticulous records of all of this and
and all the other things which they did
how do you feel about the ethical
question whether or not any of the
findings which they got from this
horrific work to make it usable in the
scientific community if it has any use I
mean is there an ethical question in
your mind whether I mind very very much
an ethical question that question has
been been debated for all of these years
by doctors but I felt that from what I
learned at Nuremberg these experiments
were not conducted with proper medical
experimental protocols in place and I
felt that it was totally unethical
because they had performed the
experiments on these victims to the
point of death without their consent
this is a question that is better
answered by the doctor
I have a daughter who is a court
reporter she just graduated recently and
she had four years of training and I was
just interested in what kind of training
did you have and were there very many
court reporters at that time was it a
pretty new field at that time and were
you able to tell people that you had to
get their report in the ER and they had
to slow down because I understand that
she can do that now court reporters have
been the first court reporters were in
the 1800s and they were newspaper
reporters for the Boston Globe and they
sat in the chambers in Congress and
wrote in longhand and they were called
reporters now our court reporters now
are required to go through two to four
years of education they become broadcast
captioners on real-time it is an
expanding field I graduated from a
business college in Chicago
I used the Gregg shorthand system of
reporting which is no longer in
existence you know what that is I passed
a high-speed National Court Reporters
Association examination at 260 words a
minute which is what there were only
four of us in the country at that time
writing Gregg shorthand in pen and ink
but we had to have that you have to you
have to pass the the high speeds
required in the testing procedures the
state of Colorado requires
225 words a minute and when I went to
Congress I read I wrote at 260 words a
minute by the time I got there the world
speed champion writes at 280 words a
minute so I mean it's a great feel and
she asks you know if you have to slow
them down in nürnberg well I you know
when I do a longer a full presentation I
tell about how the court reporters work
nürnberg we had half shorthand reporters
like I was with a pen and a reporter's
notebook half steno type reporters and
we could never nor in Congress can we
ever interrupt Ted Kennedy anybody else
who's speaking
especially a Ted Kennedy who never aims
a sentence and I reported him over a
period of three years but you just have
to sometimes we had congressmen who
loved to reel off a sentence as did Jim
Wright in Texas in Spanish and then we
wrote sounds and I went to the
congressman later and asked him to
translate for me or spell those Spanish
words in Spanish if that's what he
wanted to see in the congressional
record which nobody else could read but
in the courtroom you can if you get
behind or if you have a witness that is
not intelligible and you can't
understand it but I just don't ever
remember having to stop anybody now in
the Nuremberg the interpreters are the
ones who had the problems because we
reporters had to wait for the
interpreters to translate the the words
and I don't know German but I understand
that in German the verb comes at the end
of the sentence
and so the interpreter had to wait until
the end of the sentence to get the verb
and the current reporter waited for the
interpreter and then he telescope that
sentence as fast as he possibly could
because the next sentence is already
being spoken but at any rate if a
reporter is qualified they can handle it
yes two questions were the were there
other reporters who translate or were
they only transcribed in English for the
Nuremberg trials and when did you decide
to write your book and tell us about
that I'm going to answer your second
question first Toni thank you very much
for it this reporting these trials cost
me so many problems I was so horrified
by it that when as soon as I got back to
this country I started having nightmares
and I was always escaping through a
tunnel for some reason with four or five
small children I was escaping from a
concentration camp and therefore it
might have been Tara seen the children's
camp in a tunnel and I was trying to
keep these children quiet because the
Nazi guard was marching back and forth
along the barbed wire fence with his
bayonetted rifle I didn't want the guard
to hear the children I kept looking for
the light at the end of that tunnel this
went on for three years and it was pure
torture for me and I was so horrified
that I could not speak about it I have
empathy with these survivors and I don't
know whether we have served
fighters in this room but I've spoken to
I think most of them in the Jewish
community here in Denver but I was so
horrified I never talked about it I
never talked about it I was in the
unofficial reporter in the Denver
District Court within eight years after
I got back from Nuremberg and I didn't
talk about it no one talked about it and
I just shoved it all in the back of my
mind and thought nothing about it until
1987 when in Denver we had a high school
teacher in a high school in Aurora who
referred to the Holocaust to her senior
students as the whole of hawks and the
she claimed that she was trying to to
make her students do critical thinking
but at any rate I I was just living and
I decided to get my material and
photographs and in my full presentation
I do a PowerPoint I couldn't do it here
tonight because of time but I have 38
captured German film and I got all of
that out which I had stored in boxes for
40 years and I put together a lecture
which I started giving in 1989 all over
the countries thousands and thousands of
students who were my target audiences
and then in 1995 the Steven Spielberg
Foundation interviewed me here in Denver
and I was beginning to get
confrontations by Holocaust deniers
claiming that it never happened and in
1999 I was speaking at the Long Beach
Hilton hotel to a good-sized audience
the LA Times gave me huge publicity in
advance the day before and
the result the Hilton Hotel received
calls from quote historians asking where
and when in the hotel I would be
speaking and not whether they could
attend the hotel told them it was a
private professional association not
open to the public they demanded that
they be allowed to go in and the hotel
calls me the night before I flew him to
LA and asked me to register under an
assumed name they would put on
additional security
I flew in registered under another name
and I spoke on Saturday afternoon to
this large group my presentation is
about an hour and a half long including
the slides and at the end when people
were asking me questions suddenly the
the doors to the right of me flew open
and an armed security guard with a gun
on his yep came up to me on the podium
and said quietly I have to take you off
the podium right no I knew something was
happening and I went right with him
behind the podium out the door into an
elevator there and down to the basement
for protection so at that time I decided
it's time I write this book and recently
a doctor asked me how I felt doctors
have received the book extremely well
asked me how I felt now that I have the
book finished and I said I have found
the light at the end of that tunnel
[Applause]
they'll exist if so where are they
stored there in archives in Maryland I
say okay my notes of the Nuremberg
trials I said okay they're all in
archives and I want to tell you that the
court reporters transcript of the
doctor's trial is eleven thousand five
hundred thirty eight pages long in
archives and the staff the attorneys and
staff at Nuremberg condemns those eleven
thousand pages down to thirteen hundred
which you can get in one of the 42
volumes in the Denver Public Library on
the fifth floor in the government
documents section volumes 1 and part of
volume 2 and it was this is my
transcript and it is from the thirteen
hundred pages that I have prepared this
book and I have gotten what I considered
to be the most important points and put
them in this book so the book now you
can read the story for a three hundred
pages instead of eleven thousand
somebody back there has a question
are you scheduled to give your extended
lecture with the PowerPoint at any time
in the Denver area in the next year I
hate to tell you this but I am moving to
Houston in December however I do not
have I am booked to my eyeballs right
now into September 2006 around the
country but I don't have I just did
Regis University on March 29 to an
overflow crowd there which CNN from Los
Angeles filmed but I'm sorry to tell you
that I don't have anything booked and I
don't have time I have a commitment to
one Denver doctor to speak to a group of
doctors and dentists before I leave town
there's somebody here how did you get
the photographs and the other
memorabilia that you have the
photographs the one in the book know
that you're saying that you have art I
got them when I was in nürnberg they
were given to us and if we wanted them
in the court reporters office now the
the pictures that I have in the book I
am in the book at one point I have a bin
of legs taken off at the hips
now those pictures were received in
evidence in Nuremberg and I had copies
of them I mean for some reason I grabbed
onto everything I could get or that they
offered there and as far as the mug
shots of all of the doctors in the book
the Holocaust Museum in Washington DC at
my request sent the photographs to my
publisher
in Boulder this is Carl brunt and when
you read my book you will read about my
first day going into the courtroom and
looking at all of the defendants and
scanning those defendants in the two
roles right to left and Carl Brown sat
in the first seat in the first role on
the left seat number one none of the
other doctors paid attention to me as I
looked this was before I started writing
except this one and he was staring into
my eyes with such evil and so intently
that I was shocked
I felt the chill and then I put my head
down to start writing the Brigadier
General Telford Taylor who prosecuted
that trial noticed it and he said to me
shortly after that that he felt it was
because I was tall blond and blue-eyed
his Aryan but that's how I got the
photographs and the u.s. a Holocaust
Museum in Washington DC I have
contributed photographs in the book I
have a picture of the doctors in the doc
and I contributed that photograph to the
museum in Washington DC and several
others in there that I have okay after
you know after reporting on such hatred
and seeing such hatred in someone eyes
how do you keep hope for Humanity
how do you stay positive oh I belong to
the optimist club
I do I'm an optimist yes yes I'll have
young people responded to my
presentation very well we have done a
great job in Denver of educated the
children for 12 years I was on the Anne
Frank art and writing competition with
Teresa messenger as chairman who was in
the back of the room and we worked well
I think we started that first year
educating 8 to 18 in competition and we
had 56 entries I believe the first year
51 and the last year 2002 yeah we were
close to 4,000 and we just missed it by
about 20 we were 4,100 and slim yes yes
for 12 years we worked together to
educate the students in Denver and all
the schools we even had entries from
other states
yes how large was the network of doctors
in Germany how would would you know how
many there were that were involved in
these experiments besides your cases
that you were on and how would that have
affected the medical profession in
Germany afterwards seeing as they let
off seven of the more important
criminals how would how would you trust
the German physicians after the war the
German physicians after there were I
understood that there were between two
and three hundred German doctors who
were involved in experiments but we only
were able to get 20 now in 1945 a very
important trial occurred in Dachau this
was an American military court trial in
which they
they convicted dr. Schelling
with some of the most infamous of the
doctors and hanged them there I mean we
hanged you know seven doc I'll hanged
close to 40 now I do not know I cannot
answer a question about the doctors
subsequently but I think it's not a
happy answer there are too many doctors
who were involved in these experiments
who got away and who are still involved
today even in their 80s in the medical
practice I hope I am correct on that I
have my doctor expert up here that given
the number of genocide Oh massacres that
have occurred in the last 50 years like
Indonesia Cambodia Rwanda what do you
think we've learned the answer to your
question is we haven't that's all I can
say genocides are continuing we haven't
and I think that's a question that I
point out in my book why haven't we
learned the lessons
this dr. Ming Lee try didn't have since
he at your trial
no yes a good question everybody wants
to know about dr. Mengele Josef Mengele
who was the the angel of death at
Auschwitz who experimented on children
who would stand at the ramp and select
the the pregnant Jews to save them so
that when their babies were born he
could experiment on them Mengele was
hiding in a stable in Germany
all the time I worked there he got away
he actually was in Auschwitz when the
Russian armies are got to Auschwitz and
he knew it was the end was coming so he
any his band of 6 or 7 left and started
walking to Germany and when they got to
the border by that time American
military policemen were at the borders
and checked the information on these
people they he gave his name Josef
Mengele it meant nothing to an American
GI or to anybody at that time and so
that he was released and his family were
very wealthy manufacturers in Bavaria
and they were able to hide him on a in a
stable I mean as a stable hand on a farm
in Bavaria until he escaped to South
America okay
Charles